we got new merch to let you know thank
you guys get the Rat Life shorts in blue
salmon and sand we've also got the new
tie-dye bgty be good to yourself tease
and aqua creamsicle and indigo get that
and more only at Theo vonstore.com
um
all right
and sometimes I don't have any lotion
you know
I will um
I'll spit on my hands and rub it on my
arms
um
I don't know yeah I don't even know why
I do that I think that is
I don't know what that is but
I don't that's just
yeah I'll I'll tell you everything I um
yeah I ate half I ate half of a
butterscotch
that I found in my truck earlier
and um
yeah
I don't know why I did it but I did it
it's just that's the kind of stuff I'm
doing I guess and um anyway sorry we are
we are
good to see you we are here happy
September can you believe it or
something wrong
as they say in
somewhere else
um
sorry my brain is all over the place uh
and that's okay that's all right it's
that time you know it's that time of
year
you know the heat has gotten to people
the heat I mean it is
good it is this is when summer this is
that encore
when Summer's like okay you don't think
I'm a ball out
Watch Me Whip watch me Nae Nae
this is when summer do that thing you
know gets sturdy
I mean it is this is about hot as it can
get
it and with Labor Day you see people you
know people at Labor Day they're trying
to do grilling they're trying to grill
but man it's a tummy the sun say hey
don't a grill won't even start up
because you can't compete with a son
a microwave won't start up a match won't
strike they say nah nah
come on man uh
how you expect me to compete with this
boss man
with this Suge Knight in the sky up
there
the sun is just it's like that
this is It's week
the rest of the year is weather right
but this is that time where it is the
Sun
and and I'll say this you know um white
people don't get enough credit for
having to deal with the Sun
why people yeah white people don't get
enough credit for having to deal with
the sun man
they you know it put put a white in the
Sun
put a white in the Sun and look what
happens to them
let's don't pretend like we don't know
what happens to a white in the Sun
put an Irish on a beach
my God you better pray for him
let's don't pretend that the sun don't
like black people better
I look I think the sun is recruiting
black people man
it's trying to transition folks
it's trying to make more blacks and
Browns and semi-browns and off Browns
this
put a white in the Sun for 30 hours
and now make him walk down the
interstate he keep pretty browned up at
that point
see if somebody don't pull over and give
him a nelly CD
or cornrow his hair up
I'm just saying baby the Sun
the Sun be making it make the Sun be
making more black people man that's the
truth
or it's trying to put a Swedish person
in the Sun for 40 hours
and let him apply for a a home loan
okay what's up
that's what I'm saying man that's the
Sun be doing like that
and that's just what is this the time of
year it is when the sun this is its boss
the sun is him
right now
um
yeah we got a lot in this episode man
we got a lot we're going to get into
we're talking uh
well that way you know that reminds me
um when I was in school you know and you
had to build that solar system baby
remember that
it was maybe a third grade or fourth
grade
you had to build that Sola system which
uh like a mo you had to make a mobile
with the different planets hanging on it
in that
and the rich kids they had they came
their mom if you had a dad first of all
then if your dad had a job and your mom
didn't have to work then your mom had a
car with a hatchback right
and the rich kids you know Zachary or uh
Abigail
they would come to the school and they
had
um
they're they're they would their mom
would open the hatchback and get their
uh their solar system out
and you'd see all the planets on it made
out of a little Styrofoam ball and
everything and oh it's Q to say their
name on the side zagara
Abigail
now if you was over by us bro if you had
to ride the poor bus bro you had to get
your first you had to build your [__]
Bro mom wouldn't help you ain't had no
hot glue gun
you was doing your thing you had to do
it yourself right that's how you had to
do it I remember my solar system that
[__] had a uh orange in the middle bro
and I put it in the uh microwave for
like 30 seconds to warm it up to give it
that that sun mentality you know
so I heated that bit put it in the
middle
and then I hung whatever I could for the
other things bro I had me a cherry
tomato on there I had me a uh part of a
mitten
uh what else I had a closings Pan
um I had a butterscotch and what else
was on mine maybe a marshmallow and a
thing of tweezers that I had found in
Mom's room and that was my solar system
baby and I and you had to get on the bus
bro that was the problem
and on the bus people some people they
didn't have their their their theirs
made the other children
so they had some lurkers on there
like Daniel you know Daniel he he steal
four Jupiters on the bus bro he'll roll
off the bus with a half a pocket full of
Jupiters dog
and that was his uh presentation
and Gerald damn I remember oh man
we had this one fella
in our class Gerald bro and he
you know he didn't have a lot of brain
in him he wasn't real
he wasn't that real that brain dog you
know
and he had his solar system had I
remember it had Earth and Alaska that
was the two planets bro
that [__] had Earth and Alaska
and one night I remember we was at a
camp out or something and I remember
looking up at the sky with him and he
he he we were looking at the moon and
he's he said hey man you think
you think we'll ever land on Alaska
and I just patted him on the back a
little extra
you know because sometimes some folk
need that extra patent bro
and that's what he needed a couple extra
Pats
on the back baby but
that's what God's doing man what I'm
saying is we all have different
universes
you know we all got different we all got
different universes
um welcome to the episode thank you guys
for being uh a part of my life
um
and let me be a part of your life
what's going on uh we got a unique
episode we have um we're gonna get to
some calls
we have the Gator Boys
some of them boys they they nabbed that
gator
over there in Mississippi they nabbed
one
I mean
just one of them big daddies this thing
big boy this thing big this thing won't
fit in a condom you know what I'm saying
this thing's back so they nabbed it and
uh we're gonna talk to one of those guys
um
we had some Finance we had a fro we was
a victim of a fraud we gonna talk about
that
um and what else can we talk about got a
lot of great calls
um
what else I've been I've been feeling a
lot man I've been I've been having a
tough I've been feeling like
everything's got to be perfect man
I've been feeling like you know it's
like I kind of even just to come into
podcasts like all right I gotta be every
you know everything it's like
or just every day every last like man
everything is just like I it just
it just uh and sometimes it builds up
it's like and I don't even notice it's
going on
[Music]
um
but it yeah it but that's not the truth
and I just sometimes I'll let it build
up and be the truth or it's it's just
I can't explain it but it starts
happening in the background like
everything's got to be perfect you know
uh
so yeah I just want to call that out on
myself and just think you know like I
can't make thing I can't be perfect I
can't make everything perfect
um
um yeah
so it just okay you know
uh
uh and nobody's asking me to really it's
like it's this
it's like this self-fulfilling like or
not a self unfulfilling prophecy
you know it's like uh
it's a ridiculous pressure it goes back
to an hour it probably Associates to
when I was young you know
um
and I felt like if I wasn't perfect then
uh uh I wouldn't be cared about
you know
um
or the only way I had a chance it was
like you know I wasn't getting when I
was
I don't know I'm not trying to get in
all that kind of stuff but it was like
what I guess
it's like if I what if
it was like I guess I felt like if I'm
not if I don't the only way I have a
chance to get the what I need in the
world is if I'm perfect
because I wasn't getting what I needed
so it was like man if I I guess the only
way I can that I even have a chance I
must have to be perfect
to get the care I need you know or maybe
if I'm perfect
maybe if I'm perfect
Then I then I will have to be cared
about
you know because you know how no
somebody couldn't not care about
something that's perfect you know
um I don't know I'm not saying that I'm
perfect or anything I'm just saying
that's an old thing that would be in my
head man
and it's not even a thought that I had
or created it was like a survival thing
that happened when I was young and
[Music]
um
and I could see how a kid could think
that you know a kid could think that
so uh
but yeah sometimes that flares up and
I'm like man if I'm not perfect
then uh people are
people are not gonna like me
you know if I'm on if I'm real honest
about it
um and I know that isn't true I know
that's not true of like
my friend like as an as an adult now I
know that's not the truth but it still
doesn't stop those old feelings from uh
they kind of take over the they kind of
uh
hijack the Mainframe sometimes
and I get stuck in that space and I
don't even realize it you know
um
so yeah I just want to share I just want
to call that out to myself and
and just say yeah man you don't have to
be you you are oh you're fine
you're okay brother
you know and um
yeah I just want to call that out to
myself
because that's important to me
uh to notice and I'm grateful now that I
can even notice when that happens
sometimes so that I'm not just sitting
there and just being
a victim of it
um
we have some really nice calls some
really nice stuff and
um grateful to be here with you guys
um
well I got this call that came in right
here let's just let's let's hear this
daddy real fast let's see what this cat
has to say here because I know
what's up you little love muffin I just
heard your podcast and it's about time
coming to North pack a lot
I live 20 minutes away from
Winston-Salem and I'm so [__] excited
bro gang gang homie gang baby yeah and
that's it that'll just lead us right
into the tour dates that's what I want
to tell you we have some new ones and uh
man some really exciting stuff
um yeah we just got back from Canada I'm
gonna talk about that in a second but I
want to let you know that uh we have a
live now Norfolk VA
uh Roanoke VA and that's where I think
um
I think that's where the pilgrims
started uh Huntington West Virginia up
there up there about a Big Sandy Arena
they now call it the Mountain Health
and they used to call it the Big Sandy
Evansville Indiana uh at the Ford Center
Pikeville Pikeville Kentucky at uh on
November 16th and Winston-Salem uh
November 17th and then New Orleans
Louisiana baby November 24th the day
after Thanksgiving at the UNO Lakefront
Arena and uh
that's mad for me that's real magical
that's the first place I ever
um seen like a big concert
and uh to get to go there and perform
um
yeah
it means a lot you know and
um
yeah it means a lot man I know in a lot
of people there I know were excited
about it and um on behalf of them I'm
excited as well it means a lot just to
be uh from uh that community and that
area and to be able to go back there
and um
and I just am grateful for that support
There and Everywhere and we had some
nice calls that came in
um I just got back from Toronto
and uh Niagara Falls maybe we did it
over there and if you haven't been uh
been to the falls you need to go see it
and I was on the Canada side and you
look I got to my hotel room and I looked
out
and I and you see I mean it just is
unreal
it's just
there's so much energy there I mean you
see that River and you see that mullet
on it baby
you say damn that's a waterfall baby
at this is God you just
yeah just I mean it's just stunning you
know it's just a stunning
um it's a stunning place over there so
if you get a chance to check that out
it's worth it
um and then we spent time over there in
Toronto and
you know Toronto I'll say this man
there's a there's
really friendly folks
it's I mean it's very friendly and it's
very diverse too it is
I mean God you they got thing you've
never seen
you know
they got you know they got things you've
never seen over there
he's like damn you you're you're you're
you're a person
it's so it is a mix baby
oh
and
and one thing that's different there is
rate the racial there's not a rate you
don't feel a racial tension especially
between black and white folks there
now that of course you know I'm white or
semi-white you know and so that's
that you know I can just have my
perception you know and I grew up in a
black and white area and so
there's more history you know racial
history in the U.S but in cat and
candidates that's not there it's really
different
it's the energy when you were when black
and white people around each other it's
really
it feels real clean
it feels like there's not
there's not a bunch of faces from the
history
you know there's not a bunch of like uh
uh there's not a bunch of History
you know it just feels like there's this
history of Being Human
and that to me was
you know it's nice it's nice to see and
it's nice to feel that uh
uh so if you wanna it just was real
interesting experience man
um because it's different in America
and not everywhere in America exactly
and not always in America but I'm just
saying kind of on average and it was I
thought that was pretty spectacular man
you know uh
and and another thing about Canada
they're not there's not as many people
trying to like it doesn't feel like it's
really safe I mean it's safe
you don't feel scared you feel
you just even if somebody's mean if you
see a mean person the worst thing
they're just gonna run up and say hey
I'm mean
and then they'll run off you know
and like hey I'm mean sorry sorry about
being mean but I still am
then it'll run off
that's like the war it's like
I don't know
I think part of it is they don't there's
not people trying to get ahead there's
not as much like in America I feel like
we're so conditioned that you have to
get ahead you have to keep climbing keep
climbing
and in uh Canada they're more relaxed
there's not as much of that energy
and so when you're not
when you're not trying to get ahead as
much you're more you have more energy
just to be
you're more happy where you are
you more happy where you are if you're
not trying to climb then you get to you
you have your your energies there to
stand in the group and share with your
community
and so I think that's what I feel a lot
is a lot more people are content
and man it's nice to be around it's nice
to witness it's nice to know that that's
possible in
a place
because sometimes sometimes it doesn't
feel as possible here in America anymore
to me and I'm not trying to be a downer
I just sometimes you know
but yeah it was just
it's nice when you're just talking to
somebody and that's
they're just trying to be helpful trying
to be friendly
not trying to get ahead or do anything
just trying to be associated with their
fellow man or woman
there was something hella warm about
that
um
what else happened I'm trying to think
so that's all the traveling I've done
you've done any traveling recently
Raleigh Mal
blue chew baby you want to puff up that
Frank homie it'll do it
Bluetooth that's right maybe you want to
launch that freaking
you want to launch that Randall baby
blue chill will help you they'll do it
Bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra Cialis and Levitra
but it's in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can plan ahead and be ready
whenever an opportunity arises and
they're chewable baby you can suck you
can even I mean you can suck that you
know you can have it how you want you
can chew it or suck it down
does it work yeah yeah it does I'll tell
you that
it'll puff up that Marlin homie you know
what I'm talking about
that's right blue chew wants to help you
have better sex discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and do it and we've
got a special deal for our listeners try
Bluetooth free when you use our promo
code Theo at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w promo code Theo to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast can you believe we did we've had
seven months without football can you
believe it God it hurts it hurts when
you think about it but
the pain is over it's back
so you can tell your wife
that you'll talk to her
in February
that's right NFL is here in DraftKings
sports book is an official sports
betting partner of the NFL and they're
giving you a can't miss offer for week
one
this week new customers can get 200 in
bonus bets instantly when you bet just
five bucks on any NFL game DraftKings is
hooking everyone up with game day
greatness all customers all customers
can take advantage of two new offers
every single game day this September
just check the app to see what you get
download now and use code Theo to sign
up new customers can take home two
hundred dollars in bonus bets instantly
just for betting five bucks that's code
Theo only on draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL the crown is yours
what else happened I'm trying to think
so that's all the traveling I've done
you've done any traveling recently
Raleigh Mal
I
yes sir have you um done any traveling
recently brother
ah no I'm I'm about to
okay great and where are you headed bud
I'm going to Denver oh okay buddy wow
and how do you do it altitude how do
how do um
I don't know how to say this how do are
you do a lot of uh how do Asians do at
altitude
uh I I think we do I think we do good
okay
what are some famous high altitude
Asians are there any I'm trying to think
of one
because if I think of a mountain brother
I don't always think of
um
and maybe this is racist I mean I don't
think of an Asian on a mountain
is that
um yeah so I looked it up it says
tibetions and Sherpa are the only two
present day high altitude East Asian
ethnic groups tabitions damn
I thought I thought damn tabitions
are you tabition wow and those are high
altitude Asians huh
correct gosh boy some Red Bull drinkers
baby they're getting up there
and what else has been going on in your
life brother
um nothing much
um a good friend of mine passed
no
yeah oh man
but I'm sorry man um
and was it a uh was it a male or female
uh female oh
God that's wild usually I feel like men
die more I don't feel like I hear a lot
about women dying
you know
oh I'm sorry man
were you able to go to a service or
anything or what do you guys do for that
sort of thing
yeah we had a uh a good uh celebration
of life on Saturday oh I'm so sorry man
what kind of do um
and how old was the person Riley she was
29. oh
was it pretty sad was there a lot of
singing and stuff
yeah yeah we did a few worship
um worship songs songs that they wrote
together
[Music]
whom was there food or not there was
yeah
[Music]
what would they have
they had uh tacos oh
that's interesting I feel like you don't
see a lot of
um
talk you know a lot of
I I I feel like you don't see a lot of
like kind of tacos when there is uh
deceased
or death you know dang that's surprising
were you surprised at that
um not really she she really liked tacos
oh man
um
well I'm sorry brother
I appreciate you even showing up today
especially knowing that that had
occurred man and
um
we're gonna check back in with you I'm
happy you're here today man and I'm
happy that we're able to think about her
together and uh and I'm happy that um
that uh we're able to sit here and think
about her what was something about her
that you like do you know anything that
she liked or really enjoyed did she have
any pets or anything
um she didn't have any pets but um she
was a photographer oh wow
wow man
and now she's being developed up in
heaven I bet huh
yeah Amen brother
how you man well I'm sure they really
appreciated you going dude
um
yeah I'll check back in with you in a
little bit how does that sound Riley
thank you for being here today my man
thank you yeah man really appreciate the
help
um you know we had some people hit the
hotline we were talking last episode
about
um
getting out of poverty
if you are
um uh if you were
born into poverty or you live in it and
you've certain ways aren't your way out
what are some ways that other people
have gotten out of it you know because I
think it's important to know
um you know I talked a lot about
pressure washing in my neighborhood when
I was young a lot of people would uh do
pressure washing and that was something
that was pretty popular to get people
out of there and so I want to go to a
couple calls right here you guys hit the
hotline
985-664-9503 and responded uh with some
calls and so we want to get to those
right now
um and see what people had to say so uh
uh here we go
hey Theo uh I I loved your uh I love
your analysis of getting a pressure
washer to you know help help get your
ass through a hard time when you're
young when you're 22 you probably don't
know a lot
um uh I I am that guy I grew up [__]
dirt dirt dick poor and uh
and I got a pressure washer and I got a
paint sprayer and I I I took a job I
would I would say like some some really
good advice I make a I I I have my own
painting business now so I make about a
hundred bucks an hour dude nice
um which is [__] amazing to me
um I got a pressure washer
4200 4200 PSI Whoa man you talking that
big dog then you impregnate something
with that gun daddy you'll impregnate a
damn driveway you know you could you
could uh do DJ khaled's hair baby you
could
you'll knock a wig off a thick sister
with that I mean that's
Utah I mean that's uh dang
4200 PSI God you doing drive by Washings
that's high octane Daddy
you know you could damn castrate a
bichon with that buddy praise God baby
let's hear more
uh
and uh and I started a paint business
but I also had to learn I I learned
a lot of [__] before that you know I did
a lot of jobs before that always painted
kind of on the side and I didn't know my
side misses business was going to turn
into my real business but that's exactly
what happened
yeah that's what's amazing is you get
started in one thing and next thing you
know you're doing another thing you know
you you know you reach into somebody's
mouth to [__] steal their gum and
next thing you know BAM [__] you a
dentist
you know the small things could lead to
the big things all right that's a nice
one thank you for that call we got a
couple more that came in here too
um let's see what else we got
hey Theo coming out of the great
mountains in North Georgia
North George up there Toccoa in other
areas in Georgia the mountains of
Georgia
it's a great place to um
to hide from a uh
to hide from
knowledge
sorry I shouldn't have said that but
you find some people up there that ain't
they ain't playing with a full deck of
letters baby you know
they Alpha bet it ain't that long homie
did you find somebody got 14 letters in
alphabet
you say dang
come out so I heard you're talking about
ways to make money on the side not too
financially shut off in the first place
been cutting grass for a living since I
was 17. it's been pretty successful so
far started off with a mower and trailer
just charging 40 50 dollars a cut
now I have contracts customers I'm
getting paid up to about 500 a month so
50 Grand a year and I'm able to pay off
an employee
oh amen and that's great yeah once you
get going then you realize okay I can
hire somebody to do this and I can start
to you know uh scale up they call it you
know garyvee calls it that scaling up
or whatever they call something I don't
know but yeah do somebody yard boy
especially these days people rich people
you could do all kind of [__] to their
yard bro
you know especially you go to Atlanta
bro they have they'll have you do all
kind of [__] to the yard bro now have
you put a finger wave on the finger wave
the grass like what
they'll have you down French braid right
over by the hedges bruh
you say damn they are but they'll have
you put activator on the [__] Hedges
bro over there you say hell yeah boy
somebody's whole yard looking clean
maybe damn
so that's what you gotta remember that
bro that the things are evolving too so
what can you offer
you know you cutting grass but you could
do grass and more
you know if you cornrow somebody's
[__] cornfield that's on point
you know dang that's what I'm talking
about if them bougainvilleas bro if them
[__] are [__] they got a uh French
braid
they got them [__] rolled up
you know you gotta fade over there on
the bougainvilleas that's what I'm
talking about that high and tight
are you [__] Jerry curl a rose bush
you know it's just what can you offer
for the people
what else we got let's hear more brother
it's kind of funny because I found out
tonight my girlfriend's pregnant
I guess that's what prompted me to call
you hell yeah dude that's what I'm
saying bro
that's how look if I cut enough grass
bruh
somebody getting pregnant
that's on God homie
that's where I'm from bro
if if I do if if if if I do enough yard
work
somebody getting
pregnant
that's you know
you know what I'm saying you keep raking
bro and suddenly you rake up into some
ovaries bruh and there you are bro you
all in love bro and you got a family
baby praise God man
congratulations too man let's hear a
little more
I'm not ready for the kid I know I have
a long ways to go until I am rude
I saw that name the time to do better
for you yourselves goes around you
because uh
well man I think you can handle it
brother
you know you can handle the for you know
you handle you handle not knowing what
to do with the job and you started you
made a choice for yourself
but don't overwhelm yourself either man
it don't have to be perfect bro
you know you're gonna man you're gonna
do a great job that kid is you part of
that kid is you that's what's that's
what I think is probably real
fascinating about being a parent
and you obviously care about yourself
man you working doing things for
yourself
so all you can man you're going to do so
good man
uh bro I'm happy for you bro
um we actually have one more that came
in let me hear hey what's up man this is
Dylan um I'm from New Hampshire but I
live in Denver now I'm calling about how
to get out of poverty uh one of the best
ways to do it is door-to-door sales
your Vivint smart home selling security
selling Pest Control you know you could
go fly out to pay for your stuff it's
all commissions you got to make sure
yourself if you're tough enough man you
can make six figures your first year wow
I didn't know that buddy door-to-door
sales
yeah that's great
because dude some people these days
honestly I believe if you go to
someone's door okay and you knock on
their door
and when they open it if you say look
really honestly if you give me ten
dollars bro I'll leave right now
I bet six out of probably 15 people will
give you
10 at least eight dollars at least eight
dollars bro to get out to leave bro
because people are fearful now so I
think that's a way you could get you
know start stacking a little
hey knock knock yes you know my name is
Terry and I'm gonna be real with you I
don't know what I'm doing
but here I am
and for ten dollars I will leave
immediately
BAM [__] I'm venmo and Terry bro bye
Terry I'm venmo and Terry gotta go
sayonara Teddy hey Teddy uh goodbye
Terry
goodbye Terry oh so crazy Terry is gone
sorry that [__] gives me uh
pretty amped up man let's hear more
no prior experience you know and then
you learn to sell and you can apply that
other places you'll get a jump start in
your life and do it at any age
so that's my advice for uh people who
don't know what to do reach out to those
companies show determination they'll
give you an opportunity to make some
money and the best thing you can
practice this at uh you could practice
door-to-door sales at Home Depot
if you go back in there by the um
kitchen you know by the uh appliances
and everything they got a couple doors
set up right there a couple
you know and you just stay I would close
them stand there [__] knock when
somebody answers
try to sell them something practice
you could practice right there they got
like you know yeah usually a couple
different doors different color doors
and stuff like that and you can see
yeah knock knock somebody opened it
they're like uh hello and you're like
hell yeah you want to buy this wrench
set
you know you want to buy this wrench set
you could get anything out the store and
sell it to them you know you want to buy
this uh yarn plant
um
fishing
gear all types of stuff you ever done
any door-to-door sales rally
I have really
wonderful man what did you guys sell
um anything from popcorn to
See's Candy
oh wow and how'd you get involved with
that you said you were doing more um is
that called uh
that's not really on trays that's more
side items huh right okay
and what uh wait how do you get involved
with that
uh popcorn was for Scouts and See's
Candy was for band
and what was easier to Pedal let me what
do you think was easier to Pedal out
there and
I mean like a bike no no what was easier
to sell to folks oh
um See's Candy oh yeah why you think
I think everyone just liked candy more
than popcorn yeah
yeah that's interesting yeah I think if
you put candy on the word of on the back
of anything it's you know people are
interested in it
you know you throw in it you throw candy
on the back of something people are more
excited you know
like if you say hey you want to buy this
[__] people like nah dawg be like
hey you wanna
you wanna get up on some of this
[__] candy
people be like let me look at it
you feel me rally
I do that's business baby that's big
business let's hear more brother
um secondly
I had a question for you I keep getting
these these relationships that don't
work out and uh part of it's my fault
we're working through that in therapy
but
processing the emotions man I just keep
crying at this realization last week
that anytime I really really want to
drink and I'm alone typically just need
to cry so I've been crying constantly
man and I'm like God I'm just gonna stop
all right so the question I have is do I
just keep crying it out or should I uh
should I just buck up and you know stiff
up and live because I don't know trying
to I'm trying to love myself and get to
a place I can be good to someone else
anyway I love you man and I look forward
to seeing you when you come to Denver
okay gang brother thanks for that man
thanks for the call and just for sharing
uh what's going on with you man
um
let me try and drop in here to this uh
well I think yeah tears you got to let
tears out
you know
tears I believe that tears belong to God
you know I really believe that
oh
now a baby's Tears Don't a baby a baby a
lot of time baby just being an [__]
and that's how a baby gonna be boy
but uh but as an adult man tears really
I believe belong to God and
and a lot of times yeah you know
their emotions they're attached to
emotions
and they those emotions they take all
it's hard to get them out of yourself
you know they go through a gauntlet of
like
of on you know
takes you know you'll be surprised when
an emotion finally gets to the surface
of yourself
so those tears I feel like there are a
lot of times they're this they're sweat
man they're the sweat of the
The Gauntlet that your emotions had to
run through
this climbing through your soul
that's a that's this that's the sweat of
those feelings man that's all that is
you know hard it is hard for them
sometimes to get out and get out of your
body and get out of your brain and get
out of your heart
some of them have to go through your
through the past through time and
through your heart through your brain
through your
and through the party that don't even
want them to come out then they got a
trick that big they gotta trick the
bouncer a lot of times
and finally they get to the surface hell
yeah they gonna be sweaty bro when those
emotions finally get there
so that sometimes what I see tears as
you know a lot of times there's we see
somebody tear up they stop it I and
sometimes I understand maybe if you're
in a public place and you're feeling
uncomfortable or whatever but
man if you have a chance to let those
tears come out
I think it's important
because the God God is trying he wants
them out I believe that
um
yeah sometimes he's trying to wash away
some old pain or you know sometimes you
might be excited you get so hopeful you
know you'll tear up man and
and that's that could be tears that's
trying to water some hopes that you
might have
you know
you may have such great hopes God might
be like hey you need a a couple ounces
of water for them mixes I got you dog
now sometimes God might be you know you
God might think you thirsty and he may
see me like hey this is all I got bro
and he you know there's salt in it but
hey you can have a little you know and
that's weird bro if you just crying just
to drink them
that's always we we you know
we had some dudes in our town bro
they wasn't doing that but they was
being nasty boy
they was being nasty dude that's one
thing
God
when people are being nasty I don't know
hmm I don't know how to handle it
sometimes I
people because God people can be nasty
[Music]
and they are being nasty sometimes
I remember seeing them do it
God they was being nasty how do you feel
about that rally man when you you ever
seen people being nasty or anything
um
you know I just uh
just don't don't think about it what do
you do just drive off
yeah hmm
what's going yeah what's new with you
Riley I feel like you know I know we
haven't seen each other in a while and I
see you got that facial hair going maybe
you got that catfish rocking on Daddy I
do how do you feel about that what what
spurned that
uh I just wanted to try something new
hmm
and do you feel different with it does
it feel how does that feel you know
because I rock it you know
yeah no it feels great feels definitely
uh very different like hell
like do you feel give me five words it
makes you feel
some you know
give me some words
I feel older okay older
grown grown okay so black and older
um
I don't know I look better maybe that's
hold on that's a lot of what you guys
don't just do you just have to do a word
sorry but I have to have the rules for
the little for the game
you want to think about them yeah I'll
think about them okay
oh mine
and are you getting burgers are you
doing what for the summer time the end
of the summer barbecules
are you do you have it you do in a
barbecue you're having some people over
thanks
well
if he's having Burgers if he's having
Franks or if you got some vegan over
there and they want you to grill up a
mushroom for them
well I'll tell you this picking up
burgers and hot dogs or whatever you're
doing you can save money
with Ibotta
that's right you can get cash back
Ibotta gives you cash back on hundreds
of grocery items from produce to
personal care to Pantry Goods so you can
make sure you're beating inflation no
matter what you're purchasing either
link your loyalty account or upload your
receipt after you shop and get your cash
back it's that easy the average Ibotta
user earns a one hundred and twenty
dollars per year that could cover the
cost of an entire shopping trip
that's right get cash back right now
with Ibotta
and he bought his offering our listeners
five dollars Just For Trying Ibotta by
using the code Theo when you register
just go to the app store or Google Play
Store and download the free ebata app
that's i b o t t a
the free Ibotta app and use code Theo
that's
Ibotta in the Google Play or App Store
and use code Theo if you like auto
racing and you are into that
gasoline and rubber and damn just
Sunburn and stuff like that Morgan and
Morgan has teamed up with Richard
Childress Racing to support Kyle Busch
and Austin Dillon and are offering one
of you this past weekend listeners the
opportunity to attend a race day in Las
Vegas on October 15th oh that's awesome
they are giving one lucky winner two
thousand dollars and two tickets to see
Kyle Busch race live in Las Vegas this
October
uh entering to win is easy just go to
morganvegas.com
slash this past weekend that's
morganvegas.com slash this past weekend
no purchase necessary open a legal
residence of the 48 contigua
contiguous United States and DC who are
18 and over Swedish takes ends 10 1 20
23 for entry and official rules visit
morganvegas.sweep P that's
s-w-e-e-p-p-e-a.com
as well if you're ever injured I want
you to know that you can call Morgan and
Morgan
their fee is free unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com this past weekend or
dial pound law that's pound 529 from
your cell phone this is a paid
advertisement
all right we got a call that came in
right here uh from one of these Gator
babies right here and these these men
have been dealing with prehistoria
and prehistoria let me tell you what it
is it's before
um
before it was like trial basis when God
was trying out animals
this is way before
uh like a um a deer or a uh
uh golden retriever this is back when
God had like brontosaurus you know he
was just he was putting [__] together he
didn't know yeah brontosaurus had like a
90-yard neck
like damn what he would eat but it never
made it to his stomach and they would
die every time
they would die every time dude have a
huge meal and then you couldn't get the
food couldn't get there and he died
you know he just and then they had
triceratops and things 400 pound
forehead bro set like 70 pound body
so them [__] the second they was they
was born they took one step forward and
just
and now every one of them died face down
in the dirt
T-Rex he couldn't do [__] all he could
do is bite people
all he could do was bite people man
you know like a little pervert at a
[__] mall bro
you know they couldn't he had them
little arms he had them baby reachers he
couldn't even [__] hug his buddy
think about that
no wonder he's so angry
he can't even [__] hug
and so that's some of the early animals
God made and that's prehistoria
now some of those animals are still
lurking around
someone who's Animals still Milling
around in our world
and I want to talk to a man who captured
one of them down there in uh Mississippi
over there and they just captured a 800
pound
uh alligator can you imagine that
can you imagine your wife thinks you're
cheating on her
and you show up and you just
your arms you've got lacerations all
over
um yeah let's get to the call uh Joey
Clark I believe is the man Joey
hey what's going on Theo how you doing
man what's up boss I see you got that
Ole Miss shirt on for yourself yes
indeed man if I'm coming on a uh an LSU
boys uh podcast I gotta gotta represent
right we'll call it a truce for a little
while baby how about that man there you
go for about three or four weeks and
it's back on okay deal man I'm turning
into into a UT fan too here in uh in
Tennessee
um Joey tell me about this Gator baby
you guys caught that Gator huh yeah man
um this uh with three of my buddies out
there uh we were in we're outside of
Yazoo City and um oh yeah that's where
um uh Jerry Clowers from Yazoo City
Mississippi that's exactly right that's
exactly right uh went out there in Yazoo
City and we've been to this spot you
know over the years I think this is
probably the
fourth or fifth Gator I've caught with
these guys something like that
um so we've been to that spot several
times and y'all are Gator buddies huh
that's right that's right I've been with
these fellas a few times and and they've
been several years without me as well
um and so you get out there you guys get
out there you're in a what kind of
vessel are you guys in not a submarine
or anything huh no we're in a we're in a
14-foot John Boat yeah boy I know we
brought this thing in the uh oh that's
some Tom Sawyer Water work right there
buddy that's right that's right that
that Gator was about a about a foot
hanging off of that boat while we were
trying to get back in at night and so
what are you hook him on when you are
you aiming for this type of big gate or
are you aiming what are you trying to
catch are you guys looking for flounder
what are you guys trying to catch out
there yeah when you're out there you're
I mean in this area we've we've hooked
up and caught you know several you know
12 12 and a half foot Gators out there
and that's really what we're looking for
you know we don't you know in
Mississippi the cool thing about here is
it's not like Louisiana it's not
commercial they only give out about 900
tags a year so we got drawn in the
lottery so you want to make it count
right you want to make your Gator count
you don't want to come in there with a
little non-foot Gator if you don't have
to but uh you know nothing against that
just we've done that before right so so
we it's probably embarrassing I guess if
four men get out of a boat with a little
baby gator that looks probably yeah I
mean we've uh it's casual looking
we we saw this Gator uh just as we were
putting in right before dark and we had
no idea it was this big so we we hopped
in the boat went out there and um you
know we must have passed 20 to 25 30
Gators on the way out there and they all
look great and it's just a swamp full of
alligators out there but and how do you
can you tell like because the eyes are
usually poking out of the water can you
tell how big a gator is even just by its
eyes poking out you can tell even when
you get you know you're far away from
one you can tell if he's undersized and
something you don't want to fool with
yeah but uh you know you're out there at
night it's it's pitch black there's they
got a pump Sunshine out there to that
part of the part of the state and you
know you're out there in that in that
stuff and you got a q beam and uh you're
just trying to light those eyes up and
and go from there and does the beam
shock the gator at all does it kind of
get like a um like a does it does it
have that deer and headlights effect on
a Gator or what is that like it's not
too much gonna shock him when he's when
he fills the vibrations in the water of
your of your boat and your trolling
motor and all that that's what's going
to make him kind of kind of duck and
start trying to get away from you and
and you know he held his breath it
seemed like 30 to 45 minutes at a time a
couple times and oh wow we just had to
keep on searching him and um you know we
hooked up to him the first time and what
do you mean are you hooking him on a
spinner bait what do you got I mean what
do you even put out there yep so it's
just a treble hook what are you guys
using are you guys using chicken livers
like what do you use it what's the bait
no there's no bait whatsoever oh there's
no no no bait whatsoever you're out
there you know you've got to see this
Gator and then you've got to be talented
enough to be able to throw a uh just to
throw that treble hook throw that line
right where you want to do it okay so
you're not so so there's no bait in
there there's you're not trying to get
them to get something like a fish or it
is more you are just trying to get the
hook into his body that's right that's
right you're trying to get the hook in
his body and you know eventually we kept
on trying to hit him with one one line
at a time and we did that but he kept
breaking off and what these Gators do
um we must have we probably hooked up on
him seven or eight times I guess and he
kept on you know shaking that that
treble hook out of him but what they're
trying to do is go under logs and things
like that and and shake that that hook
out of them and then they're free
um and so that's that's kind of what the
the gist is there and do they seem nasty
like did this Gator seem like a nasty
guy or what did he say like can you get
any a semblance of what their
personality is like did he seem like a
nasty guy yeah man he was uh he wasn't
the meatest gator we've ever run across
we've run across some meaner ones but he
was very territorial you know he did the
the weird thing is we've hooked up on
some good sized Gators in the past and
you know you hook them once or twice and
now they kind of get the gist of what's
going on you're trying to kill him and
they disappear you'll never see him
again but this Gator he wouldn't do that
uh he was there in that area you know
he's just uh he's probably a hoarder
have you seen that show like my 700
pound life or something that because
that those people don't not you know
they're usually locked in their house
with magazine you know they have like
stacks of magazines and everything
that's right
over there yeah he's in his spot and
he's not trying to get out of there he's
uh he's doing his thing and uh like I
say he never left he never left the 200
yard radius force and that's just crazy
to me that they didn't happen like that
because we hooked into it for the first
time about 9 30 at night and we didn't
have that thing in the boat until 3 30
in the morning my God and so you hook
him you start getting him now how close
is the boat as are you just right next
to him
yeah you are so you know we I'd say when
you hook up on him initially you know
you're probably within 15 feet of the
Gator probably so yeah I wouldn't be
there buddy yeah I'd call a damn Uber
buddy I would not be right there I'll be
glad to send you a couple of little
videos we took on the boat so you can
kind of see for yourself on this uh if
that'd be something that would help kind
of put it together for you we'd love
that we'll play some of those side by
side while we're talking about it okay
so you get them you you have how many
hooks do you eventually get into the
gator finally at the end we did get a
second hook in and we had one the first
hook we caught which is not where you
want to catch him would be uh back at
the tail and that's that's where my
buddy Don he blind cast out over him
hooked him in the tail we fought him for
about another 30 minutes we can get a
second hook in him damn uh you know and
so kind of my job with all this is when
I'm in the boat you know we've got a
snare or whatever and my job is once
he's come up what do you mean a snare
yeah so it's like a um
no not a drum it's uh it's kind of like
um I I caught almost like a noose right
I mean it's you it you you've got a rope
on the end of it you slip it over his
head and then when you do it I just pull
that rope as hard as I can and basically
try to sit down on the bottom of the
boat until uh so there's some damn BDSM
[__] it sounds like yes indeed yes
indeed wow it's so it's crazy if you
wind up and get him at 14 feet uh three
inches so it as of today we've got still
got 24 hours left in the state of
Mississippi for gator hunting season but
as of today it's the state record wow
and how much weight was it
802.5 pounds damn boy and that missed
that missed the state record by 20
pounds so that just tells you how big
they are down here oh so it didn't even
make the weight record but it made the
length record that's right that's
exactly right
that's incredible man it is it is so
once you have both of those hooks how
are you elevating it out of the water
what's like how does your boat not
capsize yeah so you know what he's doing
when he's down there underwater he's
he's you know he's fighting and he's
down there and he's been down there at
the you know at this point you know over
that seven hour period he had been in
that water uh you know underwater the
majority of that time but they got to
come up for air right they gotta they at
some point they can't stay underwater
forever they got to come up so when they
do you got to think about it as you're
you know these guys with the two lines
are pulling him closer and closer to the
boat
um as they continue to fight him and he
continues to come up for air a little
bit more frequently towards the end and
that's you know when it gets close
enough to the boat within you know I'd
say two or three feet if you can and
that's when you want to put that that
snare around him and and hook him from
there and kind of finish the deal off
and do you choke him out does somebody
get on him how do you finish him man I'm
trying like hell to choke him out I'm
like I'm just holding him as tight as I
can until somebody can shoot him oh yeah
yeah you got to shoot him he's gonna
yeah
that's right this is a damn robbery bro
it is it's a it's a mugging for sure it
is
no no no no you got to put that bad boy
last thing you want to do is tow him in
and then you lose him or something yeah
because once if he were to break off a
rope or something he's at the bottom of
the river you're not getting it back you
know and when he after he's right when
he dies do y'all hug or what are people
like is there a celebration what is that
moment like man it's just a sense of
relief you've been out there with him
all night long and the last thing you
want to do is let him off the hook look
we had been out there for so long we
were all just getting tired and worn out
we've been working all day all four of
us just you know doing our thing and
nobody wanted to give up and we all
thought about it but at the end of the
night you know my buddy Tanner the
entire time uh he was like we're not
letting the skater go we're just not
gonna do it so he was he was hell-bent
on getting this gator in the boat oh
every Tanner I know will get hell-bent
they get hell-bent on all kind of [__]
you put a couple beers in them were you
guys having a couple beers no there's no
drinking out there there's no drinking
it's a little bit too unsafe for that
yeah we try to be as legal as we could
with getting this gator in and out and
thank God we did because now you know I
mean immediately when we pulled it out
obviously the state wildlife department
gets called they got to come measure it
and confirm it and but no no party and
the partying was after I guess the you
know over over the last 10 days just
trying to uh let all this stuff sink in
man it's it's grown and blown up beyond
our wildest expectations man man that's
exciting brother yeah and do you all
name him or anything is there any uh
uh is there anything like that deal
barium what's the what happens is there
anything that happen like that you know
so we don't we didn't name them if we
would have I wish you kind of brought
something up maybe we should do that
um but the uh with the meat we've
donated the meat to a uh to an
organization there in Yazoo City they
kind of just you know give you that meat
out
um to you know
things like that yeah they came out to
like 380 pounds of meat so it was a ton
of meat on that and then I remember they
had an orphanage by us and they would
always whenever people would cut uh that
a lot of donated meat would go over
there and sometimes I had a buddy that
was over there and we'd go over there
and eat and they'd always be eating
Gator up in that [__] it's kind of wild
to think oh it's crazy you go in there
and you see 20 freaking orphans bro no I
don't yummy yumming down on some Gator
it's just like hey man get him some
gator sausage and then let them have a
weekend you know oh yeah if they don't
have parents dude get them some decent
meat that's what I think everybody
deserves something exactly but yeah man
it's uh that that was you know kind of
the gist of the of the Gator itself and
um you know I guess with this hide we're
gonna get some leather boots made we're
gonna be looking sharp come uh come
Christmas time I guess we'll see what's
up but uh that's the plan well praise
brother thank you so much for just
jumping on and and filling Us in on some
information it's really fascinating and
congratulations on the state record man
that's amazing well I appreciate it man
it's very nice talking to you and uh
like I said it's been a wild ride and um
I'll send you those videos so you can
check that out and kind of see put this
into perspective what it's like out
there in the pitch black at night
yeah brother please do also just great
to talk to somebody
um from over there near Yazoo City
Mississippi the home of Jerry Clower are
my favorite comedian so uh thank you so
much Joey Clark we appreciate you
brother thank you man nice talking to
you all right cheers buddy have a good
one take care
what else Riley I'm sure people want to
know we usually get an update on how
your dating life is going what's going
on there bub
uh still
nothing really
really
okay that's okay well damn dude and
how's everything going I know we talked
in the past about the masturbatory
efforts and stuff you've been out there
glazing that Glizzy homie what's been
going on you've been freaking burping
that little pants yurt or what
um you've been frisbee in that little
syrup dog or what
ah still nothing
oh man you tell Raleigh Mal people are
not believing this man that you've never
you still have never ejaculated is that
true yeah it's true
brother we gotta get you on a damn
pay-per-view
I mean you could open up for Logan Paul
and Dylan Nance you could be in an early
preliminary I mean there's never in your
life
you telling me the truth Riley I am
never not even in your sleep God has
never come and touched you in your sleep
never
what
oh my God we could raffle you off to a
bunch of older gay men in Hollywood they
bro they pay half a million dollars for
you in Hollywood to be getting clean
sauce out of a damn Vietnamese fella
from the mountains
yeah um I'm I'm actually not Vietnamese
well but yeah but you know what I'm or
what are you
I'm uh Japanese Korean Hawaiian and
Norwegian
well you know that's pretty much
Vietnamese dude but that doesn't matter
man what matters is we're both
human beings baby boy and I can't
believe boy you got that clean syrup in
your son you got that 6 000 octane boy
gosh that's God's Gleek homie you that
thing coming right off the clouds of the
Lord
my God
dude if you you if you've got you a
little if you got you a half ounce of
that
and you uh
painted the toes of some of these gay
men and perverted men out there in
Hollywood my God
oh but I'm sorry that's not what we need
to be doing that's not what we need to
be involved in man I'm sorry for saying
that stuff
oh you're good you know but why do you
worry about not being able to get an
erection when you do get a woman Riley
when you because or you're now you're
saving yourself for marriage that's
correct correct but how do you know your
that your body's gonna work then
I I just believe it will when the time
comes dang boy
wow bro
that is a risk though Riley look I but
you know what man I've seen miracles
happen man I really have
I've seen miracles happen bro
and if you look I would stand by y'all's
bed and pray for y'all pray
you know buy all the marital bed or
whatever be in the next room and you
know put my hands on the wall and pray
or whatever you need it buddy
you know
yeah yeah
all right you sound exhausted man are
you tired
a little yeah it's just been a lot sorry
I keep I keep forgetting um I don't
forget that that's that you just came
from a funeral man I'm sorry and I'm
sorry for me for asking about some of
this but uh you know I just want to know
what's going on and and maybe we can
help you find somebody Riley like um
you know we'll put
um we'll put some clips over there on
the uh this past weekend social media
and see if and um you know maybe you'll
you'll meet a girl you need you want a
God-fearing woman correct I do Amen
brother does it matter what uh ethnicity
they are religious ethnicity
uh ethnicity no okay oh I mean like
Protestant or whatever
um just non-denominational okay nandama
damn okay you're getting risky boy
you're hitting that raffle boy
non-denominational baby that's the
devil's raffle baby
all right
what else do we have here
um is Arthur on the line Riley
um yeah
okay great
um I want to uh I want to deal with a
little bit of laundry now or just uh
some kind of behind the scenes stuff
really
um you know you guys we had an issue in
the past where
um Kai The Hitchhiker
and he's a famed
um
he uh you know he uh smashed smash
smashed somebody at an intersection with
a hammer
and he was that hammer baby you know
he's that freelance construction worker
and he um
he was like a national celebrity and he
and then he did
um murder he did a few murders and so
anyway uh that was a famed clip somebody
took my face and put it on his clip and
it made the rounds on social media and
it was you know funny and crazy I can't
believe that somebody made it
um but then at a certain point uh he
fought a lawsuit against me against me
and said that I was using his footage
and his
um
uh like name and like I don't know this
is using him
um and so we reached out to uh Morgan
and Morgan uh who's a who's a sponsor of
the podcast and uh my buddy Dan Morgan
is
um one of the Morgans over there and
uh and so they've been handling that
case for us and I thought it was over
with but apparently it's not uh we're
still getting stuff in the mail and um
and so that I want to check in right now
uh we have
is the only we have Arthur Petrosian
that's right nathio Hey Arthur how are
you today
good brother how are you I'm doing
pretty well man except uh you know I
keep getting hammered by this case man
this guy he's uh he's a resilient isn't
he
guy is definitely persistent
um he's he's unfortunately been able to
dance around some of these procedural
issues in federal court keeping the case
alive
um the court still has not heard the
case on its merits so we're confident
that once they hear the case uh they're
ultimately going to dismiss it out and
how many like has he fought because yeah
I've got I keep getting paperwork and a
lot of handwritten stuff and how many
like how many
things as he filed at this point
multiple motions uh multiple amended
complaints
um you know it's fun to read to be
honest uh you know every time I come
into the office and I get a handwritten
note from Kai uh from his jail cell I
open it immediately I can't wait to read
it I actually have a document that he
filed with the court so this is an
official document that he filed in
federal court and this is all public
record so anytime you file a document in
federal court anybody that has an
account could go in and look at this so
um I I think this paragraph gives you a
glimpse of what this case is all about
and what he's been doing and if you'd
like I'll read it it's actually kind of
funny yeah I'd love to yeah let's get it
so so this is Kai and his moving papers
he says
plaintiff is writing this at 5 30 in the
morning in a sweltering hot cell in a
stone Building without air conditioning
that heats up during the day and holds
the heat throughout the night he's using
a floppy shank proof pen
he typed this at the law library but he
only gets five hours once a week if he's
granted extended access and his access
just ran out and then it goes on to say
even now plaintiff has to wake up at 3
30 in the morning get his work on this
opposition done before 11 A.M or else
the sweat soaked document would be
unacceptable for filing wow
defendant and that's you in Contra
distinction and these are his words as
begin has been making comedy videos in
an air-conditioned Studio making a show
in the most literal sense of slacking
off enjoying himself instead of filing a
responsive pleading
the core can see for themselves that
during the time in question defendant
was having the time of his life hmm
well so you know it's it's going nowhere
it's just things like this that he
continues to file again there the court
in order to provide him with due process
is kind of entertaining him at this
point okay
um but we strongly believe that within
the next 60 to 90 days when the court
actually hears the merits of the case
and actually reviews our motion to
dismiss that they're going to Grant it
so will we have to go to court do you
think
I would uh you don't have to but I will
definitely be there representing you
thank you first of all thank you very
much yeah absolutely I can't glad to be
here yeah I know I'm I'm really grateful
for you guys helping man
God I mean it's just so and so I guess
if somebody's in in jail they still have
the right they can still sue somebody
they can still even if they did murder
they can still you don't lose those
rights you know absolutely and this was
this is what this case is about and
that's why we've been kind of sitting on
the sidelines for about six to eight
months is because the federal court
wants to make sure that they provide Kai
is due process rights and to hear them
out uh again eventually this case gets
dismissed but for now we're going
through the motions and making sure that
the court hears them out wow
and do you guys get a lot of a lot of
cases like this
you know we don't handle a lot of cases
like this but we pride ourselves in in
fighting for the people and we consider
you a good friend Theo so uh We've we're
all hands on deck on this case we've got
multiple people pushing it uh we've got
experts lined up as well too just to
make sure that you're going to be
protected from every angle so you know
it's it's kind of an exciting case it
provides some comic value for us yeah
just because it's it's different than a
lot of the other cases
but yeah I almost would I almost would
well first of all thank you guys so much
man uh you know uh Dan you know Dan
Morgan's is a nice guy and we have a lot
of mutual friends and and um and thank
you guys too for for supporting the
podcast and I know you guys mostly
handle like personal injury that type of
stuff that's right right but it would
almost be crazy what if we got to go do
like a deposition or something that
would be wild wouldn't it that would be
wild it would be very entertaining
um we would probably have to take it in
jail in Kai's cell probably I don't know
if he'll get extended hours to go to the
law library to do his deposition from
there
but that would be exciting exciting to
do
yeah appreciate it man Thanks for liking
at least recognizing that uh this is
kind of entertaining along the way I'm
sure it is a little bit different than
normal
um yeah I mean he's definitely kind of a
notorious figure so
yeah
um well we're excited to back you up if
there's anything else you need you let
us know thank you hopefully hopefully I
will not but I appreciate that
you got it all right have a good day
brother
you too
wow so that's interesting you know
that's uh but you know I'm grateful that
you know if people if you that you don't
lose all your rights you know I mean
what a what a fortunate country where
you can
do a murder
and still
go and have rights
I mean that is you don't get some places
you don't even get that you know
I'm sure there's a lot of countries
where you don't get that
where if you do a murder that's it
you know they're like hey buddy you do
you do you do the murder
and then you that's all you doing
um sticking in the legal in the legal
space I want to talk about uh something
that has been tough for it's I want to
talk about something
um
we our podcast was defrauded we were
stolen from
um we were taken advantage of a lot of
ways to say it uh the company that did
it is cast media
and the man that did it is Colin
Thompson and I'm gonna put his picture
in here
um
and
uh it's
I don't know exactly how to say this I'm
gonna do my best
um we're part of a larger group of
podcasts that were uh stolen from
right we were part the in total I've
just between talking with folks there's
up to four million dollars that I know
of that people were taking advantage of
uh we're in the six figures I know of
podcasts are in the seven figures
um
and Colin Thompson that's his name I
want to say his name so you know it uh
people get taken advantage of a lot in
business and and and businesses use
tactics and stuff to hide to hide
themselves and uh you know they'll use
bankruptcy or the threat of this or that
and and um
and and he may get my money
that's okay you know I'm fortunate that
I can still have touring and then I uh
can take care of myself but you [__]
with the wrong rat Colin I'll tell you
that brother and uh
and I'll just tell you guys what
happened
um we had a deal with this company right
and and it was started off good and then
it started to get where we were getting
less of our payments
and we were reading the ads we do the
ads you know we read them out loud and
we and and you guys support some of them
and thank you
um
and then it got to be where we're
getting paid less of the payment we were
owed
and they sell all the ads a year in
advance so you're kind of stuck into the
year right
and the advertisers were paying Colin
Thompson and Cass media and they weren't
paying us they would pay us a little bit
and they had a reason why and
so one of the craziest Parts was like
there was like we kept asking you know
hey we have to get paid man we have to
and we weren't getting paid and so
finally I was able to make a new deal
um and just cut ties completely I made
sure that everything you know they
breached our contract and so I was able
to cut ties and then they come along
Colin Thompson comes along and he joined
there's a new company that has a stock
that's going live soon right or it's
coming out or something this company
called podcast one or live one right
I he they they get me on a call uh with
I think the guy's name Rob Ellen yeah
that's a guy's name Rob Ellen
um
and his brother is Doug Ellen
who's like a screenwriter and I think he
did his brother was pretty successful
um but they get me on a call with this
guy Rob Ellen right and
and they tell me
um
they tell me that if you come over to
our new network
over to this new network podcast one
that will pay you in some of what you're
owed in stock
right but the stock hasn't gone public
so they're trying it it felt like to me
they're trying to leverage our podcast
and other podcasts
to then make their stock do well
um
and then if that happens then we'll get
a share of our money right like
it just
the whole thing to me felt really uh
seedy and the worst part to me was
I said well
what about Colin Thompson
I said that guy is a crook
and they said he's gonna be
um he'll be
they said we felt like he's done a good
job and that he would be part of the
team still
so how that's just I know some of this
is a lot of Insider baseball man but to
me it was just [__] just it felt real
dirty
and it felt like
um
just no respect for podcasting no
respect for the work that we had done
um you know to get paid by the
advertisers and then not pay us and then
uh for Colin to lead us in this
direction and say well if you join this
other group before their stock goes out
that uh
that then will pay you in some of the
stock but part of that will be based on
if we're there for it to do well
I don't know man but I know what it
feels like to be taken advantage of uh
and I wouldn't do that to these people I
wouldn't do that to Colin Thompson I
wouldn't do that to cast media and um
and so I say this just because I don't
want this guy taking advantage of
anybody else
a lot of times in business practices
especially in like um
entertainment stuff A lot of people are
able to snake away
and they're able to slip through and use
tactics and uh shell games and [__]
um but you [__] with the wrong rat
homie I have a voice
and a lot of other people are forced
into these bad deals because they don't
they're afraid to speak up
they're afraid to speak up man and uh
that's not what our show is about and
um
yeah
I just want you guys to know that this
is the man
we put his picture up on the thing on
the YouTube
and the amount of money that I from from
other people podcasters they've said is
over four million dollars
um
and
yeah it's just this shit's [__] wrong
and I don't also understand how a
company expects me to come wanted me to
come over there
to boot what felt like to me they were
using me to boost their stock price and
I don't say that at an ego but we've
done well
and that they get all these podcasts and
well that'll boost our stock price then
we'll go public with the stock and then
based again on their backs
the stock there'll be there will be
money there so it's like it felt like
y'all gonna try to [__] me twice homie
well
no no thank you uh so yeah you can keep
that money
um you can't keep it we'll see how it
plays out but if you do end up keeping
it man
you must have needed it you must have
needed it I don't know I mean it doesn't
make me stoked but
um
but you can't get me to shut up man
you can't get me to shut up
and uh if that's the cost of it for me
to say my [__] piece
you have any other podcasters wanted to
say this [__] right now but can't say it
[Music]
so
anyway
um
yeah that's who I just want you to know
I want you to know about Colin Thompson
I want you to know where I've heard he's
going to be working at and I want you to
know that he's a crook and to me it's
criminal
um but it the the way that people are
able to cheat and lie and manipulate the
system
um
you know he went and got Neil sacker who
worked with Harvey Weinstein to jump on
the calls I mean he just
I don't
[__] it's just [__] kind of sad man
and
yeah but I just wanted to speak up for
myself man I've waited a year to speak
up for myself you know he he they put us
through so much [__] and I don't
know if there's other people over there
that did it too and maybe we'll get more
information I don't know or this may be
all you ever hear about it you know
um and so I didn't really know how to
the best way to do this but
um yeah I wouldn't do that to somebody
and he they did man they did it to P I
mean some of these people's podcast is
all they had man
and these [__] did that bro so
I'm sorry about that
um and I'm sorry for them and yeah I'm
just happy to have a voice for myself
and that's one thing that we built here
that that he had nothing to do with he
had nothing to do with in fact he stole
on our backs once and I'm not letting
these people do it to me two times So
for anybody that had to take that that
sucker deal over there uh this voice I'm
speaking about uh for all of us man
um because I know that some of you guys
have said to me that you wanted to say
some of these same things and
I don't mean that out of ego I just mean
that um I don't know I feel
uh
you know I don't know sorry maybe I
shouldn't have said that part I don't
want to speak on behalf of those people
but
um yeah
I just wouldn't have done that to
somebody and uh I'm happy to be able to
speak for myself
I'm so thankful I'm thankful to you guys
to the listeners that we have this place
here
um
and that this is what we try to do and
I'm sorry I've been making this about me
this past five or six minutes or
whatever but
um
foreign
but this was the only public place I
could do this where I feel like it would
have some effect because to me this
guy's like the Bernie Madoff of
podcasting and uh
and that almost glorifies him in a weird
way but um I wanted to be able to say
that sorry I'm just rambling but uh I
wanted to be able to speak my peace
thank you
um with that said man let's get back
into something here
um I want to say this you know I just
saw I saw on Twitter where Max Holloway
who is from Maui was sharing about how
uh a donation that was made to the Maui
food bank and then Dustin Hollow Dustin
Poirier and the good fight Foundation uh
match their efforts a ten thousand
dollar match and on behalf of this past
weekend uh we want to do the same thing
I know there's a lot of listeners out
there who think like well how can I help
and what can I do and so I'll um so
we're gonna do that together here
um and so yeah we're gonna match that
ten thousand
um
there's some Charities also that Kelly
Slater shared about the surf man and so
we'll see uh but we want to we're going
to match that ten thousand dollars from
Maui
um and that's this past weekend that's
us doing that so if you're a listener
and today you're feeling like I wanted
to do something for the people of Maui
uh what you just did and we did that
um and yeah sorry I hope that doesn't
sound egotistical sorry man my brain's a
little all over the place from sharing
some of that uh
you know I think when I get taken
advantage of it attaches it to like old
feelings of [__] and um
yeah it makes me feel uh
it makes me feel
it attaches to Old feelings of like that
I don't have any Worth or something I
don't know I don't know sorry uh
all right what else can we do anything
else you want to say Riley
um you know just that you know I'm glad
that my family is safe
um my I have some family out in Maui
um some cousins out there that they're
both firefighters and you know I'm just
glad everyone's safe really huh
firefighters so were they were they they
must have been involved huh yes uh they
all lost their homes oh man
oh
[Music]
man the world as soon as there's just so
much going on it feels it feels just
really it feels like a lot doesn't it
yeah definitely well I'm sorry brother
I'm sorry that that happened for them
and you know that that community over
there God there is nothing more special
if you get to witness it in your life
um
then some of the connectivity of some of
that community over there and uh Maui
the other Islands as well um
it's just something really really
special
you know uh
so our thoughts are still with them man
and
yeah I'm sorry that that happened but
thank you for letting us know that Riley
let you know let us know a little bit
more about you you know
and that's important and if we ever get
that boner to launch I mean we might
have to get a couple firemen to put that
thing Out Boy
boy we gonna get that Branch to burn you
know we gonna get you out there just
syrup in that little Hammer baby
um yes I uh yeah thank you guys man for
being a part of this episode and um
yeah it just does you know it doesn't
have to be perfect you know
um you ever feel like that Riley
I do
yeah where do you think it comes from
man or what do you think about it
um yeah you know it just you don't you
know you don't always have to be perfect
yeah because we can't be right
right
yeah so it's a Fool's errand isn't it
yeah man
but what it almost feels like we like we
should be that where we need to be does
does it ever feel like that to you
sometimes yeah
and what do you do then when you when it
happens
uh I just
think again that I'm you know
I don't have to be perfect
yeah
that checks out man that checks out
um
yeah
we don't have to be perfect you don't
have to be perfect I mean you are you're
you're fine
uh uh so yeah Praise Baby thank you guys
thanks for the love and support and just
um yeah I just I can't I feel like I
just say thank you over and over again
uh
by
hoping to make the most of this week man
hoping to hide from this summer I think
this is one last week is flaring up
and then we could do what you know we
could see what Winner's thinking about
so
um you guys be good to yourselves baby
you deserve it and you too Riley okay
thank you Theo yeah you bet man thank
you man thanks for being here
[Music]
and I made a dollar I ain't spent but
where it's going ain't killed me yet I
still get where I'm bound to go
I'm making it
I'm making wrong
feel right
[Music]